Welcome back everyone this will be my full star
wars the book of boba fett episode one video there
were a whole bunch of easter eggs and references
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel i'll be doing videos for all the
episodes so be sure to subscribe to get them
all we're also doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and just leave your favorite moment
from the episode on the video there'll be seven
episodes total if you guys didn't know so we'll be
running all the way week to week into january and
february and this will help set up what's going
on during the mandalorian season three this is
meant to be kind of like the mandalorian season
2.5 as you see it picks up after the events of
the mandalorian season 2 post credit scene where
boba fett goes and kills bib fortuna but careful
for spoilers from the episode if you have not
seen it yet we'll just start at the beginning
and go through shot by shot talking about easter
eggs wtf moments and references as we go along
starting with the episode title chapter
1 stranger in a strange land which is a
reference to boba fett being taken in by the
tusken raiders after he escapes the sarlacc
and sort of being a stranger to the culture of
being a crime boss like there are a couple times
later in the episode when fennec shand says this
would go easier if you just accepted their ways
like the ways of the other criminal underworld
under bosses stranger in a strange land is also
a direct reference to a robert heinlein novel
of the same name and that's about a man who's
raised on mars but then comes to earth and
has to acclimate to terran life and culture
but as you can see because this is part of the
mandalorian universe like it's a mandalorian
spin-off they're using chapters the same way the
mandalorian series uses chapters to mark each of
the different episodes but even though this is
meant to be a spin-off of the mandalorian and
set during the same timeline after the events of
season 2 the reason why they're starting over with
chapter one is to just distinguish it as its
own small mini-series thing like there's only
supposed to be one season of the book of boba fett
but the idea is that they'll do this for other
characters in the series so eventually they might
do the same thing for say like bokeh tan crees or
other major star wars characters but the actual
opening scene from the episode basically recaps
everything that happened to boba fett after he
went into the sarlacc in turn of the jedi like
we knew we were going to get that story but they
basically opened the episode with that but the way
they start on jabba's palace at night while boba
fetts asleep in the bacta chamber the regeneration
chamber is meant to be one kind of a darth vader
reference because darth vader anakin skywalker
basically has to spend every waking hour when he's
not in the armor inside a bacta tank healing his
damage but it's also meant to be a more specific
callback to the return of the jedi scene where
everyone in jabba's court is sleeping pretending
to sleep in some cases when princess leia comes
back to rescue han solo like you're entering
jabba's palace at night while everyone is asleep
but because boba fett has been cleaning house in
jabba's palace so to speak in present-day there
aren't that many people that's why the throne
room itself is empty but they basically start
on the throne itself because that's so important
to the actual series him claiming jabba's throne i
believe the writing on the throne itself is meant
to be in hud ease because that's jabba's language
it also has carvings of the rancor on both sides
of it because jabba kept rank horse as pets for
many many years ludwig gorinson did the theme
music for the boca boba fett just like he did
the theme music for the mandalorian series and
as you could probably tell they're trying to
do it in the same style as the mandalorian theme
music but with much darker overtones because this
is less of a space western like mando is in more
of a crime thriller like the godfather in space
boba fett being the godfather in this situation
they flash back to his earliest memories of his
childhood on kamino during attack of the clones
because he is very literally a clone of jango fett
just raised without any special enhancements to
accelerate the aging process like he was meant to
be a completely unaltered clone then him finding
janko fett's helmet after mace windu beheaded him
this party's over then he has ptsd flashbacks
to his time in the sarlacc pit we get a much
bigger scene of him escaping the sarlacc pit
there's been a couple versions of this that
they've depicted in the legends canon like the
really old stuff and then the newer stuff as well
so if you ever wonder what it looked like
inside the belly of a sarlacc well now you know
he sees the body of a stormtrooper nearby who's
half digested stealing his air supply just to
get a breath and as you guessed it uses
his flamethrower because mandalorians love
their flamethrowers like mando used it in almost
every single episode of season two and season 1
but he uses the flamethrower to burn his way out
of the sarlacc so that he can climb the rest of
the way through the sand nearby you can see the
wreckage of jabba's sail barge he wasn't in the
sarlacc for that long like he was in there for
a good long while but i think that he'd been
out of the sarlacc for at least a year or two
by the time we see him during the mandalorian
season two episode one like he'd been living
with the tusken raiders for a good long while
as we see him meet them for the first time
during this episode but then the job would show
up to steal all his armor off of him and that's
obviously where cobb vanth bought the armor from
like he says oh i bought it off a bunch of jawas
that was actually right out of the brand new star
wars books cobb vanth was a newer character
they introduced after disney bought star wars
maybe we'll see timothy oliphant come back on the
show because he is still around and on tatooine
but they leave him for dead until the tusken
raiders come find him and take him back to their
community just sort of dragging him along the
chain gang i'm guessing we're gonna flash back
a couple times to this camp of tusken raiders as
he slowly becomes part of their community most of
you probably just got done seeing the dune movie
obviously we have the fremen during that if you
didn't know the sand people the tusken raiders
are inspired by the fremen from the dune series
so you see a couple times in the episode them
using water in really efficient ways just like
the fremen do during the dune series like they use
the water and the fluid from the insects juices to
revive boba fett so they can take him back so that
he won't die on the way back later in the episode
you see him being forced to dig for little gourds
that contain water and moisture that they can use
to drink and because we go back to the tusken's
camp during day you actually see much more of
their people like you see a bunch of younglings
which reminds you of anakin skywalker killing
all the tusken raider younglings during
attack of the clones the children too
they're like animals and i slaughtered them
like animals you notice another roadie nearby
who's also being held captive like them with a
massive hound nearby they're kind of like the
fearsome dog-like wolf-like creatures that they
domesticate on tatooine and uses hunting dogs we
saw mando treat one like a pet during mandalorian
season two episode one like he's figured it out he
knows a little bit about tusken radar culture boba
fett is kind of learning about it on the fly they
use some of these scenes though to give you an
idea for what his character is like and what his
morals are what his code is that he lives by like
he spares the life of this youngling here when
he could have killed him like he's not as bad as
anakin skywalker was like i might be a scoundrel
i might be a degenerate but i'm not gonna go kill
all these younglings but this is also meant to be
a parallel for the mandalorians just in general
like tin jaron was not born a mandalorian he was
taken into their culture and adopted their creed
their customs becoming one of them so boba fett
kind of does the same thing throughout the first
couple of episodes here probably becoming one of
them at least briefly till he can get his ship
in his armor back finding a new respect for the
tusken raider people then he has to hold court
because now that he's sitting on jabba's throne
he has all these vassals that he has to treat
with and take tribute from them sitting at court
listening to his subjects the same way any king
would in a classic setting they do a big suit up
montage obviously this is a big difference
from the mandalorian series because mando
mostly does not take his helmet off even though
that's kind of changed in the last season or so
i always love a suit up montage but the other cool
thing here is that you just get a reminder for
all the different weapons that he has all over his
body they make a c3po return of the jedi reference
when they both say they need a protocol droid
so that they can actually understand what all
the different aliens are saying the droid that
they actually do have announcing everyone is an
8d8 droid he's another droid from jabba's palace
in return of the jedi whose original function was
to just assist ev-9d9 the dok strassi transdosian
character who's a local administrator of one of
the city centers on tatooine as boba fett says
his former employer when he was a bounty hunter
is also played by robert rodriguez if you didn't
recognize him he's kind of changing his voice just
a little bit i believe he's also playing the mok
shaiz's mayor of most espa character the ithorian
that we see in the other trailers that they
really only reference during episode 1 here you
hear his voice speaking during the trailers and
it sounds just like robert rodriguez's voice who
is this who enters unannounced no damn so it just
sounds like robert rodriguez is playing multiple
characters throughout the series he's basically
the showrunner to the director of all these
episodes so the other funny reference here when
the doc strassie transdocent character is talking
to him and he says that's weird i used to work
for him it's also meant to be a meta joke about
temuera morrison himself literally working for
him while they're filming all these book of boba
fett episodes it seems that the tribute that he
brought him is a bantha pelt but all these scenes
with him meeting these people taking tribute is
just meant to show you the dynamic he has with the
rest of the criminal underworld on tatooine when
they reference most espa like may you never leave
moses but that's just where the city center this
character manages is in most espa is also the city
where jabba held the pod races during phantom
menace it's just one of the other really major
cities on tatooine next to most eisley one of the
other major spaceports so then mentioning it here
also foreshadows them going there physically
later in the episode like that's the city they
travel to later we'll probably visit a couple
different cities on tatooine during the series
but then like i said they referenced this mok
shaiz's mayor of most espa character who sounds
like he's going to be one of the major antagonists
early in the series this character is meant to be
his major dormo another twilight just like bib
fortuna was jabba's major dormo and they're just
creating a little bit of drama here with their
relationship like no no no you're supposed to be
giving us tribute no no the mayor didn't come
here but he does send his thanks so it's just
meant to be this big political dick swinging
contest between the two of them and we see boba
fett visiting him during the trailers like i said
so it sounds like they will have a big gunslinger
standoff moment eventually boba fett isn't a
psychopath but he doesn't suffer fools either like
fennec shand mentions jabba's menagerie like back
in the day if you'd have looked at jabba the wrong
way he would have fed you to the rancor jabba's
menagerie is just meant to be a reference to his
small zoo of exotic animals and monsters like the
rancor so there are other monsters that he kept it
wasn't just the rancor but there will be some
trap dooring happening during the series like
you can't have scenes in jabba's throne room with
the trapdoor without actually using it on someone
at some point you'll also notice fennec shand is
calling him lord fett now because boba fett is
now crime lord as they call jabba lord jabba they
also use this scene with the gomorian guards to
give you a better sense of boba fett's code like
it's not the same code as the mandalorians like
i said or mando's code it's not quite as hardcore
as that but he says he doesn't torture people but
that doesn't mean that he's a nice guy he'll kill
you on the spot if you cross him which they sort
of pay off later in the episode with a big fight
in the streets against the other assassins i'm not
sure who this other new bounty hunter character
behind them is in the armor but if you think
you know write it below in the comments then we go
back to mos espa like we saw during phantom menace
just give you a slightly different view of the
city i'm not sure which droid this giant walker
in the background is that's walking past them but
these robot dogs kind of remind me of the real
life boston dynamics robot dogs like a slightly
different version like they change them just a
little bit but it's the same basic build in real
life as those dancing robots that you probably saw
those internet videos of there are a couple new
characters and aliens droids that they introduced
during the episode but most of them are characters
or versions of characters that you've seen in the
older movies the original trilogy or the prequel
movies fennec shand references jabba's litter
like the giant floating platform that he always
traveled around on mostly because he got too big
and fat but also the idea that people took it as
a sign of power and they might think him weaker
for not using something like that which is also
something that they pay off with the big street
fight with the assassins like no i'm not weaker
just because i walk around on my own two legs the
name's boba fett put some respect on it then we
actually see max rebo's band at least a new form
of the band from the mos eisley cantina we've been
to the mos eisley cantina a couple times during
the present day of the mandalorian series and it
kind of seems like it's fallen on hard times like
it's more of a toned down dive bar now so maybe
because this bar seems like it's thriving so much
in most s but that's why max rebo's band has come
here it looks like they've added an r5 droid as
one of their drummers the episode notes just lists
this song that they're playing is a variation of
the classic cantina song theme music from a new
hope but the bar in general is just meant to feel
like the scene from a new hope in the most island
cantino with a lot of the same aliens like a lot
of these aliens will look familiar to people they
have a bunch of r5 droids serving drinks which is
another reference to jabba forcing r2d2 to serve
drinks on a sale barge during return of the jedi
the dealer droid working the sabacc table seems
familiar if you remember where they've used this
before just write it below in the comments i
can't remember the last time i saw this but if
you couldn't tell they are playing sabach then
we meet madame garcia whip the owner of the bar
here which is called the sanctuary she's another
twilight but she's being played by jennifer beals
one of their first big celebrity cameos on the
show i'm sure there's going to be plenty more
of these plenty more recognizable actors showing
up playing other alien characters she seems like
one of the very few people so far on the show
that we've met who's willing to play ball with
him right away like she gets it right away and
they return their helmets filled with tribute
one of the other big differences between him and
the mando is that he offers his helmet up to be
cleaned he gives it away basically to the two
twilight servants mando would probably just as
soon kill someone who tried to take his helmet
but obviously it's meant to be set up for the
payoff of them getting the helmets back with a
ton of tribute inside them the whole fear versus
respect mantra that fennec shand has just sets
up the street fight with the other assassins
in his vicious takedown like they wind up killing
most of them and then taking one of them back like
he legit smashes one of them with the same moves
he used with his gaffy stick from mando season two
and legit just blows one of them up with one of
his rocket launchers it's a pretty decent close
quarters brawl fight you just see him soaking
a ton of damage like he is really tough but
then like right after he tells the good morning
guards take me to the back the tank immediately
because even before the fight he still had severe
damage from the sarlacc that was still in the
process of healing so he's already operating at
a physical deficit they also use this to sort of
give you an idea for what fennec shand's abilities
are with hand-to-hand combat we've seen her
sharpshooter skills during the mandalorian season
2 but we haven't seen a lot of her close combat
abilities but as a lot of you probably suspected
based on the scene earlier when he was holding
court talking to the twilike who was serving the
mayor of mos espa but it was probably the mayor
who hired these assassins because he left them
with a threat saying don't be surprised if you
get visited by another delegation the assassins
are probably meant to be that next delegation
but then back in the bhakta tanki flashes back
again to the tusken raiders again forward in the
timeline they finally pay off him being accepted
into their society after he saves that young link
from the giant creature in the desert when you
see these moisture farmers being attacked by
the gang of regnikdos we actually saw boba fett
taking them out in one of the trailers so he'll
probably pay them back in kind for what they
did to this moisture farmer here the symbol they
spray paint on the building is just the symbol of
their gang so above effect can identify them later
the scene in general is meant to give you kind of
a ptsd flashback for owen and brew large during a
new hope getting attacked and killed by the storm
troopers when boba fett is talking about escaping
he references anchor head because it's a big
spaceport we'll probably visit that later in
the series r.i.p to this rhodian though when the
giant goro mortal combat looking creature with
four arms pops out of the sand to kill them it
didn't seem like he really had that much interest
in escaping anyway so this seems kind of like a
mercy killing for him i'm not sure what kind of
creature this is meant to be though i think that
they created brand new for the series but it could
be some easter egg or reference for something from
the deep lore in the show notes they just call
it a quote-unquote sand creature which is why i
think that it's a brand new creature for the show
and most of you probably picked up on this while
he was killing it but the way bob effect kills it
strangling it with his prisoner's chain is meant
to be a big call back to her to the jedi for the
way princess leia killed jabba the hutt with her
own chains the leader of the settlement giving
him the gourd of water is just meant to be a sign
that they've accepted him as one of their own like
okay you're cool dude then just like during the
mandalorian series over the end credits they have
the concept art depicting the plot of the series
notice in one of these they have a c3po droid head
on a little platter on the floor here in jabba's
throne room didn't see that in the actual episode
but i do love the funny easter egg here but
just to explain what's going on with the other
mandalorian characters while this is happening in
present day it's been a small time jump since the
end of mandalorian season two mando still has
the darksaber he's still with boca tan and the
night owls trying to rally more support steal more
supplies and ships from the empire grogu is still
traveling around the galaxy with luke skywalker
doing his jedi training while they're also looking
for other force sensitive candidates for luke to
train if you did spot any other big easter eggs
or references in the episode that i didn't mention
in the video just post them below in the comments
like i said you'll see a lot of familiar
references to aliens creatures places things
from the original trilogy on tatooine as well as
the mandalorian season one and two and the prequel
movies that took place on tatooine like phantom
menace my full book of boba fett episode 2 video
will post next week like i said there'll be seven
episodes total that'll set up the mandalorian
season three we'll probably also get a bunch of
mandalorian characters crossing over like grogu
mando maybe even bo katan probably some
other classic trilogy characters too maybe
other classic bounty hunter characters as well i
know people want to see some of the classic bounty
hunters come back everyone click here for my
brand new spider-man no way home alternate ending
and deleted scenes video and click here for my
doctor strange multiverse of madness trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!